[Music]
can we look forward to more than one
peter parker in the upcoming spider-man
after the announcement of jamie foxx who
returns in his role as electro even
while the rumors are now spreading about
the upcoming spider-man 3.
as the recently relatively reliable u.s
side phantom wire reports
andrew garfield toby maguire will appear
at the end of the film to help tom
holland spiderman
defeat his opponents if you also believe
variety benedict cumberbatch will also
appease doctor strange in the new spidey
movie meanwhile
sony has also commented on the rumors
surrounding toby maguire andrew garfield
and could not confirm that this casting
news is true
however they have not denied it either
it remains exciting to see where this
goes and it would definitely
be an unbelievable cinematic spectacle
as entertainment weekly reported this
week actress gal gadot will soon play
the egyptian pharaoh cleopatra in a new
film
she follows in the footsteps of
elizabeth taylor who last played the
historical figure in 1963
gedot's companion and director patty
jenkins will take a seat in the
director's chair
this announcement has been preceded by a
real talk of war between the major film
studios in hollywood in recent weeks
netflix apple universal warner brothers
and paramount among others are reported
to have been interested in the project
in the end paramount is supposed to have
defeated the others and can
now call cleopatra its own this is a
particularly outstanding move by the new
chairwoman of the paramount motion
picture group
emma watts she has only been in office
since june 2020 and has set a first sign
towards competitors with leita
calagradis
a screenwriter has been found who
through a collaboration on the
monumental filmmatic center
has experience in the filming of
historical stories a release date for
cleopatra is unfortunately not yet
known after the surprising success of
mad max fury road in 2015
the prequel furiosa is slowly but surely
starting to take shape after the
announcement a few months ago
as the industry magazine deadline
reports the hollywood star's anya taylor
joy chris hemsworth and jaya abdulmatin
ii will be the leading acting trio
particularly in the foreground is taylor
joy will follow in the footsteps
of charlie's theron as the main heroine
after appearances in split
glass and thoroughbreds the 24 year old
is currently
one of the most thought after young
stars in hollywood and could give her
career proper boost with furiosa
in terms of content it's all about the
young furios and the background before
she joins the crew of the cruel
immortan joe about the roles of chris
hemsworth and jaya abdulmatin ii we can
only speculate at the moment there's a
rumor that hemsworth might play a
character called dementis
his face is horribly disfigured by a
huge scar which is held together with
staples
whether this will actually happen
however has not yet been carved in stone
of course
the prequel will once again be directed
by george miller when fury orso will be
released is still
unclear at this time it has been seven
years since the end of the recently not
quite so celebrated serious daxter with
michael c
hall nevertheless the production of the
us channel showtime still enjoys a
remarkable fan base
and after season 8 the show does not end
at all as showtime lets tax the return
for a new season
as hollywood reporter reports the
revival will compromise 10 episodes and
will bring back both lead actor michael
c hall
and showrunner clyde phillips attention
a short review of the events at the end
of season 8 follows
the series ended with serial killer
dexter committing his last necessary
murder
and killing his sister deborah in
hospital after the burial at sea
dexter decides to take the boat into a
raging storm
and not to make his escape with anna and
harrison the last scene shows him as a
bearded hermit living a lonely life
somewhere in the woods
fans speculated did he fake his death or
is it all a construct of his imagination
we can only hope that the upcoming
season will give an answer to this
question
and we are looking forward to the
release in fall of next year
a few days ago disney announced that
it'll make pixar's latest animated
adventure
seoul available exclusively on disney
plus starting december 25th
2020. on the international market disney
will nevertheless be considering
bringing the film to the cinema
soul is by far not the first film that
can be seen on disney plus instead of
the cinema because the global
corporation cost quite a stir a few
months ago
when the cinema release of mulan was
cancelled and offered for a hefty
surcharge on its streaming service
but mulan will not be available for a
fee for too long either
as disney plans to offer the live-action
film free of charge to its subscribers
from december onwards
the immense success of disney plus even
seems to change the company structure to
be more precise the company wants to
rely more on a direct line to the
customer in the future
this means streaming will be preferred
to conventional cinema releases
in an official statement disney ceo bob
chapek
reveals that the company is deliberately
positioning itself to significantly
increase its growth
[Music]
bye